estamos de vuelta con ustedes para las
noticias económicas de con jorge hurtado
jorge regresamos o para hacer las
actualizaciones de ya se conocieron los
resultados después de dos días de
reuniones de la reserva federal de eeuu
que se dijo bueno angela el principal
anuncio es que dejó sin cambio los tipos
de interés de referencia en ese país
entre el 0% y el 0.25 por ciento aunque
dijeron que podrían iniciar pronto la
retirada el estímulo monetario que
tienen con el multimillonario programa
de compra de bonos según el presidente
de la fed jéróme power se podrían dar
las condiciones para la disminución de
este programa mensual de compra de bonos
que representa unos 120 mil millones de
dólares mensualmente esto será definido
en la próxima reunión a inicios de
noviembre el banco central
estadounidense disminuyó sus previsiones
de crecimiento económico hasta el 5,9
por ciento este año frente al 7% que
habían proyectado hace tres meses
asimismo elevó levemente las cifras de
implantes de inflación pasando del 34
por ciento al 4,2 por ciento para
finales de 2021 la inflación angela es
motivo de preocupación para los
estadounidenses
debido a que se encuentra por encima del
5% y es cifra récord en un repaso por
américa latina jorge ahora nueva reforma
económica en ecuador así es el
presidente guillermo lasso anunció que
personalmente va a llevar a la asamblea
de su país el viernes un proyecto de ley
que será su propuesta económica y social
para los próximos cuatro años
laso dijo que su reforma incluía una
revisión de las tasas impositivas
reformas a nivel laboral del mercado
financiero comerciales y tributarias
asimismo pretende aumentar los impuestos
a las personas que ganan más de 25 mil
dólares al año que son alrededor del 3,5
por ciento de la población activa laso
intenta conseguir angela 30 mil millones
de dólares de aquí hasta 2025 en
inversión privada y de esta forma
contrarrestar los indicadores de pobreza
y desempleo que se disparará un producto
de la pandemia los bonos en dólares de
ecuador mostraron un rendimiento de
alrededor del 25 por ciento en 2021 nada
mal para un mercado emergente el
directorio del fondo monetario
internacional está listo para aprobar un
desembolso de 2 de 1500 millones de
dólares y en argentina mientras que
continúan las renegociaciones con el
fondo monetario internacional el país
hizo un abono a su deuda así en medio de
la crisis que vive argentina canceló un
pago de capital por mil 880 millones de
dólares al fondo monetario internacional
mientras negocia con ese organismo un
acuerdo de refinanciación de deuda por
unos 45 mil millones de dólares este
pago es el primero previsto en el
acuerdo de auxilio financiero firmado
entre argentina y el fmi en 2018 cuando
el presidente era mauricio macri ese
acuerdo desembolso préstamo por 44 mil
200 millones de dólares una deuda que en
la actualidad angela tomando en cuenta
los intereses y la variación en el tipo
de cambio asciende a 45 mil 455 millones
de dólares para pagar argentina recurrió
a parte de los derechos especiales de
giro dinero que el propio fm y
desembolso hace un mes el país
suramericano debe pagar en diciembre
próximo otros 1.800 millones de dólares
de la deuda del fm y vamos a seguir
hablando de deudas porque hay
informaciones sobre el pago de la que
tiene la inmobiliaria de china
evergrande así es la empresa anunció que
llegó a un acuerdo con los tenedores de
bonos y asumirá el pago de los intereses
de la deuda que tenía como plazo este 23
de septiembre precisamente una filial de
este grupo anunció que había resuelto el
pago de la multimillonaria deuda aunque
no especificó el monto de la transacción
evergrande tiene otras deudas urgentes
que ascienden a más de 80 mil millones
de dólares en pagos de intereses de
bonos también se conoció que el banco
popular de china inyectó 90 mil millones
de yuanes al sistema bancario lo que
calmó por ahora los temores de un
contagio inminente de deuda en los
mercados esto es visto angela como una
señal de apoyo a los mercados de parte
de pekín mientras se preparan para lo
que sería una de las reestructuraciones
de deuda más grandes de china la deuda
de belgrano asciende actualmente a los
300 mil millones de dólares 'jorge por
favor los indicadores de la jornada
bueno world street cerró en verde luego
de que la fed abogó por un enfoque menos
agresivo de lo que temían los analistas
y en américa latina'
también cerraron en verde principalmente
en brasil motivados por el optimismo
luego del anuncio del gigante asiático
ever ground de que asumiría su deuda
y las cifras del día la cifra del día
angela es 65 millones de turistas
ingresaron a méxico desde estados unidos
entre enero y agosto del 2021 lo que
representa un aumento del 112 por ciento
con respecto al 2020 gracias a ustedes
ya volvemos con más en france 24
[Música]